Today we are flipping the script and having you ask us
any questions that you want.
So who's ready for some Q and A?
Or we like to call it.
Drew and A.
(audience applauds)
With Ross!
All right. Let's get started.
First up is Vicky. Where's Vicky?
Hi Vicky.
Hi. Hi Drew, hi Ross.
Hi Vicki. I love that you stand up.
It's so, like scholastic.
It's like show and tell, right?
Yeah, totally.
Yeah.
Vicky, what is your question?
So I have a four year old. He loves to draw.
Markers, crayons, paint, anytime he sees something
that he can draw with he starts drawing.
So I got a couple of his drawings here.
Oh.
He's so proud when he draws them.
He gives them to me and he says, "Mom, look,
don't you love it?"
I have no idea what these are.
(Ross laughs)
I don't even know what to say,
because I couldn't even tell you what he was thinking.
Can you help me figure this out?
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
(audience laughs)
(Vicky laughs)
I'm getting potato people
that are actually like walking in the snow
or some type of trail, and like those two are hanging back
and the other two have made it forward or?
Oh yeah. I was getting like a solar system at first.
You know what I mean?
Ooh, celestial?
Yes. Like the, yeah, the-
Go to the next one.
The next one.
All right.
I mean, I see an airplane.
Okay. I see the inside of a refrigerator.
Like the ingredients, you know what I mean?
This is like a weird Rorschach test, isn't it?
It is.
Yeah.
Also, I you're an attorney?
I am.
Well, you know, you just need to negotiate here
in this situation.
Mm-hmm.
Maybe ask him some questions
about what's in his mind when he's drawing them.
Okay.
Yeah. Or buy him a book about Jackson Pollock, right?
That's a great idea. Okay, thank you.
Great. And you may have the next big artist.
You might have Ban Rowe in the family.
(audience applauds)
Thanks Vicky.
(upbeat theme music)